there are times when we make history any
major assembly of the United States
government most commonly the state of
the union while the rest of the nation
lies in worry that needs to change there
has to be a member of the president's
cabinet sequestered and protected in
case of an attack that person ultimately
protects the line of succession to the
presidency your secretary read a book
falling down like what the hell is going
on I said put the phone down
okay and so in the context of our show I
play Tom Kirkman the designated survivor
and so in our highly fictionalized
version of this Kiefer Sutherland
becomes the president sir thanks the
show is gonna be about the aftermath and
picking up the pieces and how this
basically every man this mr. Smith sir
place your left hand on the Bible and
repeat after me becomes the president of
the United States I Thomas Adam Kirkland
do solemnly swear somebody who is not
prepped or primed or at all ready for
this position preserve protect and
defend the Constitution of the United
States so help me God
you see this normal guy in complete
shock when this happens our economy is
going to go over a cliff and the
Iranians are just seizing the moment and
you have to see how he evolves into
being a productive president what do you
want me to do general declare war what I
think is interesting over the long view
of the show is that age-old question you
know do corrupt people ascend to power
or does power corrupt I have to do so
here is this very good person and what
is going to become of him over the long
haul so president your life with five
four and I haven't gotten to read those
episodes yet so I don't know either so
I'm waiting to see three
my fellow Americans